the handing on your she is geometry of
the derivative another way you recall is
it's a visual approach to
differentiating but also you're actually
going the other way which hasn't got a
name that you can call it ante
differentiation but we'll deal with that
a lot later on what's the idea
and this is like actually
differentiating with that'll work
ok this is what a function looks like ok
so you might notice the axes are all
labeled a bit differently at the top
you've got Y ok I've been a little bit
naughty for the sake of brevity I'll
call the next one why - why - so first a
second so the idea is what we want to do
is even though we don't know any
numerical values here ok we can read off
the features of this graph Andrew tell
us about each of the derivatives and
also as you'll see later on it goes the
other way - okay so with your other
color what I want you to do is first
let's take Nate of all of the critical
points that we know about critical
points ok now I can see 3 on this graph
can you tell me what they are
there there there what in fun can you
tell me what they are ok good so I've
got a max point yup okay I've got a
minimum turning point yeah and in
between the 20 points I have a point of
inflection now points of inflection
there be tricky so what I recommend is
you get your ruler out okay and you
stick it over on the left hand side and
you move it across now what you want to
look for is the point at which it's no
longer all concave one way or the other
okay so for instance someone should put
this lid back on for instance you can
see if I put the rule in here that's
pretty obvious everything to the left is
concave down and I can keep doing that
for a little while and then if I've gone
here is they are gone too far okay so
there must be some point in here that I
can say well it looks kind of like it
has no concavity so an easy way just
most graphs it depends on the ones
you've got most points of inflection
tend to be about halfway between turning
points okay me notice that it's a sort
of pattern not always but often okay so
I'm gonna put it somewhere okay so now
again take your ruler we'll do the first
derivative first cuz it's stationary
points right what this stationary points
tell us about the first derivative it
should be zero right so take your ruler
and ruled down from your turning points
from your stationary points down to your
first derivative
okay um you actually could but I'm gonna
leave it for now I think this is
sufficiently okay because what I want to
say now is alright at these two points I
should have stationary points so I
should have the first root of being zero
so these two sorry these two will be
intercepts right for the first
derivative now
what happens after that I want to come
back to my top graph okay and I want to
notice what it's a shape tells me about
the sign of the first derivative do you
remember us thinking about this so to
the left of the turning point what's the
gradient like well it's positive right
because the graph is increasing and then
zero okay in between the turning points
the gradient is negative and then it
resumes being increasing so if you like
this is equivalent to is shading regions
for down here okay because to the left
of this right I should be above the axis
should be positive in between it should
be negative they're actually following
the axis now on one quick question where
are you going to expect the derivative
to be lowest where should the derivative
be Louis it would correspond to the put
inflection right because that's where
it's steepest right you know here you're
not very steep at all because it's fixed
this station right here you can see for
a steeper until this point and then you
stop getting steeper and you start
getting shallower again right
so therefore this point here should
correspond to the lowest point of our
first derivative okay so this is what
I'm gonna have
okay and in fact you should be able to
take your ruler and draw it down from
that point of inflection we should line
up with this by text
okay welcome back go see how it's done
sorry okay so a couple of things let's
say on this graph here okay
stationary points correspond see roots
for the first derivative well what does
that imply cuz for it for for a
quadratic right the vertex will always
be between halfway between the roots
that's exactly right yes so if you
didn't catch that right when you have a
cubic you're putting inflection it's
always exactly halfway between your
turning points but as you increase power
it's like saying X to the 4 you're still
going out 10 points but the point
inflection will be off to the side that
we skewed that make sense yeah okay last
one let's do the second derivative which
is very quick because this is like
something cubes this is like something
squared so this is going to be a
straight line right now this point of
inflection corresponds to a root for the
second derivative okay
so I'm gonna pass through there and you
can also see have a look here right this
is concave down this part of the graph
and this plan has come came up so
concave down beings a negative scenario
and concave up means a positive second
review right so this is the kind of
second riveted I'm expecting okay tada
finished so that wasn't too bad was it
by the way you'll notice like I don't
know any of the distances here or
anything like that or scales so this
parabola could just as easily omit this
parabola okay it still has the same
station where it stores the same vertex
and in the same way this could be you
know really
it's still obey the same laws